loin de moi l'idée de remettre en cause
ou la neutralité du gouvernement où
l'indépendance des magistrats
mais enfin monsieur le premier ministre
dans un pays où aujourd'hui quand on
marche dans un parc à villejuif quand on
marche dans une rue à metz quand on
marche dans une gare à paris on peut
croiser à tout moment quelqu'un qui
dispose d'un couteau et qui peut à tout
moment nous dire puisque c'est
maintenant au rythme des déséquilibres
et qu'à ce moment là il n'avait pas
toute sa conscience
qu'est ce que ça veut dire est ce que ça
veut dire que ces gens là sont
irresponsables pénalement pour toujours
à terme
où est ce qu'on va et si demain monsieur
le premier ministre la turquie où nos
amis kurdes nous renvoie des tueurs de
dèche et que c'est tuers défendu ce qui
est logique par des avocats qui diront
mais au moment où ils ont commis des
crimes ou des massacres il était sous
l'effet de drogues
il était sous l'effet d'embrigadement il
n'avait pas alors leur pleine conscience
jusqu'où va-t-on légitimer la violence
le risque pour la république je ne vous
demande pas monsieur le premier ministre
ne répond se remettant en cause la
magistrature loin s'en faut et je
respecte le travail des magistrats mais
je vous dit le gouvernement la
république se doit de protéger tous les
français
[Applaudissements]